let's say i have a bucket of aqueous
solution and it contains some weak acid
in it and so weak acid we've done this
multiple times
it's in equilibrium with its dissociated
state
so it would be an equilibrium let me
write the
aqueous so it's a weak acid where the a
could be any other kind of molecular
group that could be the conjugate base
of the weak acid so that's in
equilibrium
that's in equilibrium
with
some
hydrogen ions so it'll produce some of
them but some of this is going to be
around as well
plus
its conjugate base
a minus
aqueous
and just like we did with the strong
acid titration let's measure its ph
so i'll do that right here
and let's say our first actually i don't
wanna i wanna do a little higher
so let's do it right there so let's say
our first pa so let's see let me make a
little scale here so this is
zero let's say that this is
that right there is seven let this right
here is 14. so our first measurement of
the ph when of our solution we have
maybe a liter of it let's say we have
one liter
of our solution we don't know the
concentration of this thing
but let's say our first measurement we
go and we say okay it's got a ph of i
know something here let's say it's got a
ph of 3. so it's acidic not ultra acidic
but it's acidic
so it's got a ph of 3 right there this
whole scale on the left hand side this
is all ph just like in the last video
this is
ph and ph is going up as you go up the
scale that's our first measurement now
we're going to titrate this weak acid
just like we titrated the strong base
and what and normally when you do this i
mean you can't in theory titrate with
anything but you normally titrate if
you're titrating a
weak what an acid whether it's weak or
strong you always titrate with a strong
base and if you are titrating a base
whether it's weak or strong the the
reagent or the thing that you're going
to add is going to be a strong acid so
in this case
even though we're tight where even
though we're going to drop some drops
into a weak acid we're going to drop
drops of a strong base so we're going to
use let's use sodium hydroxide again
so naoh and just to make things
interesting to make the math a little
interesting let's say it's a 0.5
molar
solution and we're going to add it in
increments of you know if we could add
it in little hundred milliliter
increments a tenth of a liter but the
interesting thing is really the shape of
the curve that forms or the titration
curve of the ph curve so
what's going to happen as we let me
write the
what the the reaction of naoh just so
you have that in your head naoh
sodium hydroxide and i did this in the
previous video it it dissociates
completely in water
and so it turns into n a plus all of
this is aqueous of course
plus o h minus so when you throw even a
little bit let's say you throw in you
know this is 0.5 molar solution so let's
say you throw in
milliliters 100 milliliters
that's equal to 1 10
of a
liter
this .5 molar that's its molarity so it
says hey i'm gonna have half a mole of
this stuff
or really of this stuff i'm gonna have
half a mole of hydroxide ions for every
liter so in one tenth of a liter
that means that i'm going to have
what i'm going to have half of that so
i'm going to have 1 20 or
.05 moles
so let's say this point right here is
100 milliliters i've added 100
milliliters of our solution that's going
to have 0.5 moles of oh because remember
we could say it's 0.5 moles of this but
whenever this is in solution it
dissociates completely into this so if
you have 0.5 moles of this you really
have 0.5 moles of this this will be in
this form completely because it's a
strong base so if i have 0.5 moles of
this and i throw in to throw it into
this solution what's it going to do
it's going to start sopping up
sopping up some of our hydrogen ions so
it's going to increase the ph so the ph
is going to increase
peach is going to increase and it's
going to keep increasing right it's
going to keep increasing right this is a
buffer but and this is a key thing to
remember this is going to sop some of
this thing up but this is a buffer this
is a a weak acid so it's an equilibrium
so it has this reserve
over here
of the acid form so when you start
lowering this by adding
by adding a strong base to it to sop
this up
what's going to happen the reaction is
going to move in this direction to kind
of backfill to fill or almost replace it
won't get quite to where it was before
but it's going to it's going to it's
going to
dampen the the stress on the on the
equilibrium so what's going to happen is
the concentration of your weak acid is
going to go down it's going to try to
backfill this stuff and but every time
this the reaction goes in this direction
this is going to go up
right remember nothing is stopping up
the the conjugate base up here right
we're just sopping up the hydrogen ions
as we sop up more and more hydrogen ions
this reaction goes more and more in the
rightward direction but as it goes more
and more in the right way direction
we're just adding more and more to this
and we just keep taking and the base
just takes more and more of this out so
essentially when the base is taking this
out it's really taking this out and con
or sticking half of this out it's taking
the h part of this out
because that converts to that and it
gets sopped up by the by the reagent the
the strong base and all of this ends up
on this side as a as as the as the
conjugate base so at some point when we
have added the exact same amount of
o-h
as there is of this stuff as there is a
really of this stuff plus the hydrogen
when we've added when we've sopped up
all of the hydrogen what's going to
happen
well you at that point you're
well right when you got above that point
when you start adding even more you're
going to start getting very basic you're
going to start you know it's just going
to skyrocket up the ph because then
you're adding ohs and they're not being
canceled out by any hydrogen over there
and there's nothing to kind of backfill
the hydrogen so you're going to get to a
very high reaction but what happens when
this has kind of
this neutralizes so when the o-h when we
add enough of that sodium hydroxide
that it
that this is completely neutralizes
this and this and all we have left is
that
well you might say oh maybe we have a ph
of 7 because you know all of the acid is
neutralized but we don't have a ph of 7
like we did with the strong base because
here as we sopped up stuff we kept
adding conjugate
we kept adding
conjugate base over here remember and
it's a real base it actually has basic
properties if this was a strong acid you
might say oh i have you know if this was
hydrogen chloride i still had the
chloride over here but chloride even
though it's the conjugate base it has no
basic properties it does not increase
the ph of a solution but this stuff
right here does increase the ph of a
solution and we've done that in previous
videos so once all of this is stopped up
your equivalence point or the point at
which the number of moles of this is
equal to the number of moles of this is
going to have a high ph it's going to be
like
it's going to be like right over there
and then as you add more and more of
your reagent or your strong base your ph
is going to get higher and higher and
approach 14 or even go above it so your
titration curve is going to look
something like this
it's going to look something like this
and once again you look at the steepest
point on the curve
it's right there
and you say okay that's the equivalence
point that's the point at which i had an
equal amount of hydroxide having sopped
up all of the hydrogen and i've run out
of all of this stuff to backfill the
hydrogen
so you look at your equivalence point
and you say okay if that equivalence
point was when i added i don't know
maybe that's when you added two liters
of your
reagent
so you added two liters of your reagent
your your your basic reagent right here
or your titrant i think or titrator i
think that's another word for it how
many moles have you added was two liters
is point five molar so you've added one
mole so here you've added one mole
one mole of o-h
of o-h which implies that and when you
added one mole of o-h you sopped up all
of the whatever mole you had of this so
you clearly had one mole of that
so over here you clearly your original
concentration
of your
i mean you really could say your
concentration of your h a plus your
your initial equilibrium hydrogen is
equal to one molar now in most chemistry
classes
this number
is way bigger than this number for most
weak acids and you could look at that
because if you look at some of the pkas
for some weak acids you'll see that this
is some you know
this is well i won't go into the math
but this number is a lot lower so this
is an indication essentially of your
initial concentration of your weak acid
so you essentially just keep titrating
it figure out the inflection point you
say hey the inflection point happened
when i added two liters of the of the
titrator to it which corresponded to one
mole so therefore i must have had one
mole of my original acid in the equation
now another interesting thing so if you
said okay i had one mole one mole of my
original acid in the equation so you say
this was
one molar originally before i started
titrating at all and if i say that this
is a one liter solution then i know what
my this is one mole not one molar but if
i know it's a one liter solution now i
know that originally i had one mole in
one liter so i had a molarity of one
now let me go over something else that's
interesting about these
about a a basic
reaction actually let me do that in the
next video because i think this one's
getting a little long